chers amis quel bonheur de vous
retrouver aujourd'hui pour ce conseil
national décentralisé et voulue par
notre président laurent wauquiez merci
cher jean claude guibal de nous recevoir
dont pas si belle ville de menton merci
cher eric ciotti de nous accueillir dans
son département des alpes-maritimes et
je voudrais adresser un salut amical à
renaud muselier président du conseil
régional de provence alpes côte d'azur
[Applaudissements]
consacré ce conseil national à l'europe
ne pouvait mieux tomber
au lendemain du sommet européen et alors
même que les prochaines élections
européennes de 2019 constitueront un
rendez vous décisif pour l'avenir de
l'union dans ce débat essentiel il nous
reviendra nous les républicains de
porter un projet européen puissant
réaliste et ambitieux au moment même où
la voix de la france en europe c'est
malheureusement perdu faute de porter
une vision et des propositions qui
répondent concrètement aux aspirations
comme aux inquiétudes légitimes des
peuples
on a souvent dit que le général de
gaulle était un homme né au 19e siècle
qui avaient largement anticipé les
enjeux du 21e siècle avec emmanuel
macron nous avons un président qui
regarde l'europe d'aujourd'hui avec des
lunettes hérité du monde d'avant-hier ce
qui est frappant en effet pour qu'ils se
livrent à l'exercice un peu fastidieux
de la lecture de ses principaux discours
c'est de constater à quel point sa
vision européenne et date est figé et
j'ose même dire archaïque notre
continent ne peut plus nier les effets
de la mondialisation qui a ravagé notre
industrie de production est décimé les
classes moyennes il connaît des
bouleversements géopolitiques d'une
ampleur inédite dont l'immigration de
masse constitue le péril majeur
c'est un défi pour chacun de nos pays et
pour l'union européenne toute entière
l'angélisme le bon teint la
culpabilisation trop facile amplifie une
abominable misère humaine
exploité par deux criminels passeur
aucun peuple du monde pas plus en europe
qu'ailleurs n'accepte volontiers
l'immigration de masse
savez-vous l'idée et cela c'est à
ministre d'autrefois hubert védrine dont
nous aurions aimé qu'il ait la même
lucidité lorsqu'il était ministre
socialiste la solution bâti liait relate
de centres d'accueil dit contrôler sur
le seul européen passe sous silence la
question essentielle de savoir comment
ont tari le flux l'europe que propose
emmanuel macron c'est toujours plus de
fédéralisme désormais habiller sous le
concept brumeux de souveraineté
européenne
sa suggestion de mettre en place des
listes transnationales pour les
prochaines élections européennes a été
heureusement rejeté par le parlement
européen en particulier grâce au pp
présidée par notre ami joseph dole et à
nos députés européens derrière leur
président from cool que tous en soient
remerciés l'europe vue par emmanuel
macron c'est toujours plus de
technocratie de centralisme
communautaire avec la création écouter
mes chers amis de 12 nouvelles instances
et de quatre impôts et taxes européennes
au risque que l'europe ne se brise sur
les lames d'une bureaucratie sans âme
qui fait fi de la volonté des peuples
l'europe vue par emmanuel macron c'est
la priorité donnée à des meccano
financier budgétaire au détriment des
réponses urgentes à des enjeux majeurs
qu'il néglige la nécessité que l'europe
se dote enfin d'une vraie politique de
préférence communautaire
pour défendre nos entreprises nos
emplois et nos produits agricoles
mais il est des sujets mes chers amis
sur lesquels ce président observe un
silence coupable
comment gérer à long terme le défi
migratoire
comment lutter contre la montée du
fondamentalisme islamique
quelle réponse apporter à la progression
du multiculturalisme si éloigné de notre
tradition d'assimilation à la culture
française
voilà les angles morts du maquereau
nisme dans les moments importants de
l'histoire de la construction européenne
la voix de la france avait pourtant
toujours su se faire entendre
comment ne pas penser à l'énergie et au
brio avec lesquels nicolas sarkozy avait
su pendant la présidence française de
2008 puis à nouveau en 2011 mobiliser
l'union européenne pour résister aux
conséquences provoquées par la plus
grande crise économique et financière
mondiale depuis vingt-neuf et souvenons
nous que la voix de la france était
alors brillamment porté à bruxelles par
des ministres des affaires européennes
qui s'appelait jean leonetti ou laurent
wauquiez
[Applaudissements]
comment ne pas penser aussi à la veille
de son entrée au panthéon à simone veil
elle qui était si attaché à la
réconciliation des peuples de notre
continent et qui fut la première
présidente du parlement européen
oui on peut l'applaudir chaleureusement
cette grande et belle figure de simone
veil qui prendra place demain parmi les
illustres auquel la patrie veut
solennellement exprimé sa reconnaissance
ce n'est que justice
mes amis refonder l'union européenne
pour la sauver c'est peut-être fidèle à
la mémoire de simone veil
[Applaudissements]
malheureusement au fil des discours
fleuves et incantatoire du président de
la république au fil des leçons qu
emmanuel macron assène avec beaucoup
d'arrogance à nos partenaires aux
allemands pour leurs excédents
budgétaires aux italiens pour leur
politique migratoire au pays de l'est
européen sur leurs concessions
conception de la liberté
eux qui ont passé un demi siècle
derrière le rideau de fer
la voix de la france mes amis s'est
perdu en europe
oui nous les républicains nous avons une
responsabilité majeure en particulier
pour éviter que cette élection ne se
réduisent en france pays fondateurs un
face à face stérile entre les partisans
d'un vieux logiciel n'est au fédéral
déjà est obsolète et ceux qui ne veulent
plus de l'union européenne ce sont deux
impasses également catastrophiques
sachons nous montrer à la hauteur de
cette responsabilité
ce sera aux militants de la france que
vous êtes de faire gagner une union
européenne dans laquelle nous croyons
notre projet mes amis sera j'en suis
certaine peut-être le plus compliqué
mais aussi le plus fécond notre famille
politique a toujours été traversé par
des sensibilités différentes par des
approches diverses sur la question
européenne
nous avons su dans le passé et faire de
cette diversité est une richesse
pourquoi de le pourrions-nous plus
aujourd'hui
à cet égard je veux saluer la densité
des débats que nous avons eus ce matin
sous la présidence subtil de jean
leonetti je veux remercier tous ceux qui
ont contribué et particulièrement tous
ceux qui comme michèle alliot marie
comme valérie pécresse comme christian
jacob
notre bien aimé président de groupe
comme bruno bretagne au walling verte et
tous mes amis de l'équipe dirigeante que
vous pouvez applaudir parce qu'ils font
un travail formidable
[Applaudissements]
ils ont apporté leur contribution à la
réflexion commune comme notre président
laurent wauquiez les y avait invités
[Applaudissements]
reconnaissons le certains observateurs
attendaient que nous deux écharpes y ont
gentiment sur la question européenne
avez vous entendu dans les débats de ce
matin des différences infranchissable
non nous avons la même conviction
fondamentale dans un monde désormais
multipolaire seule une europe puissante
peut porter efficacement la voix des
peuples qui la composent et
singulièrement celle de la france
notre continent a trop tergiversé quand
il fallait agir
il s'est perdu quand il fallait avancer
la liberté
mais sans la protection l'élargissement
mais sans l'approfondissement la
concurrence
érigé en dogme et l'idéal européen que
nous avions jadis s'est brutalement
brusquement enrayer à nous à nous de lui
redonner corps et perspectives nouvelles
protéger les peuples européens n'est pas
ignorer la souffrance d'autrui
je récuse les procès trop facile de ceux
qui adorent donner des leçons et propose
si peu de solutions le rôle d'un
dirigeant n'est ni d'attiser les peurs
ni de les ignorer
comme le dit victor hugo on ne va pas
aux vrais ardéchoise au mic les temps
que nous allons vivre oblige et à la
lucidité et au courage
alors oui oui chers amis de la lucidité
du courage il nous en faudra avec vous
et à travers le projet européen que nous
allons bâtir ensemble avec tous nos
militants dans nos fédérations avec tous
les français qui nous soutiennent
autour de laurent wauquiez notre
président nous réaffirmerons
l'engagement européen des républicains
[Applaudissements]
un engagement fort en faveur d'une
europe qui protège ses citoyens et fasse
respecter les frontières face aux
dangers liés au terrorisme islamique ou
au flux renouvelé et préoccupant de
l'immigration clandestine un engagement
fort en faveur d'une europe capable de
renouer à travers de grands projets
communs avec l'esprit de conquête qui a
si longtemps animé ces peuples dans le
domaine des sciences des technologies de
la connaissance et de la culture un
engagement fort
et je terminerai sur ce point car je
crois que c'est le plus important
un engagement fort en faveur d'une
europe qui n'oublie pas qu'avant d'être
une construction institutionnelle elle
est d'abord une civilisation un modèle
de société dont nous voulons défendre le
droit à la continuité historique
l'identité et les racines et transmettre
les valeurs intacte aux générations
futures
[Applaudissements]
alors oui oui les républicains croient
en l'europe
si cette europe est capable de se
transformer se transformer pour protéger
les peuples et les aider à aborder le
monde à venir avec confiance
je vous remercie